buddy the hair is looking magnificent
magnificent as always hey man
it's uh you know it's grown it's growing
and flowing
it's good to see it that's like that's
the star hair right there that's like i
mean you've always had the star here but
this is the star here this is a big deal
man mighty ducks
game changers like it's kind of like
well the convergence of like all of you
like in
a role it's amazing yeah man it's uh
it's really cool it's a
it's a trip to be a part of for sure i
mean to
to to combine hockey and disney and and
you know
childhood like mighty ducks yeah man
it's it's wild
there are several moments on set where i
had to go like pinching is this real
especially you know looking across
and seeing gordon bombay on the other
side of the bench like that was
that was a trip well it's well not to
like
just say that name out loud when you
even think about it like even in the
interview i was like i had to just say
gordon bombay
like when i when i saw him like amazing
you know
um lauren graham was saying that you did
such a good job like she was she was
complimenting your work so much and
you're
just kind of like who you are on set
what was it like for you to actually
get a chance to work with her and work
with emilia uh
that's so nice to hear um yeah lauren is
incredible
emilia was incredible steve was
incredible i mean that whole
the whole process like especially when
you you know
you come in and like those guys were
attached obviously from the very
beginning and lauren's such a
such a powerhouse and and bombay
i mean as i grew up watching him and
more than just the mighty ducks you know
he was a huge
huge part of my childhood um and uh
i think they really broke the mold for
the the old saying of
you know don't meet your your idols your
heroes because meeting them was
was fantastic and and beyond expectation
you know when i first got to set
um actually emilia was one of the very
first people who i who i met when i when
i got to set he made it a point to show
up early and to
and to meet everyone and to um not shake
their hands because obviously he was
covered but
in another world they would have been
shaking everyone's hands and saying
hello
um and then to work with lauren was was
amazing as well you know
a lot of the stuff that we do in letter
candy is very gilmore girls ask and the
speed of it and the
and the rapidity and like the improv and
stuff like that so
you know we vibed on that and then to uh
to sort of be welcomed into their into
their circle was pretty it was pretty
amazing it was a really cool experience
that's pretty amazing dude uh hockey is
in your blood it's like the family
business did you talk to your dad about
like how to do coach t like did he give
you any pointers
you know it's funny um because coach
he's a young coach obviously he's like
he's my age i'm not most of most of the
coaches you see in the nhl are
are finished their their playing careers
they're a little bit older than i was
when i played coach t
but um academy coaches are a different
story altogether and i played for
academy teams and you see a lot of these
guys who might not have made the nhl
as players in their and their route into
the the big leagues is through coaching
and oftentimes they
start out in these academy programs with
with elite
young athletes 12 13 years old so you
know i
played for a couple of of coach t esque
type guys and then
you know growing up in a hockey family
playing minor hockey and having both my
brothers playing minor hockey and
playing spring hockey and summer hockey
i met a lot of coaches like coach t
and met a lot of parents like the ones
on the ducks so
um you know i got lucky my dad wasn't
quite as
quite as mental when it came to our
hockey uh i think he got he got pretty
heated behind the bench a couple of
times coaching pro hockey but
that's a that's a whole nother story for
sure yeah
i knew a couple coach cheese do you
think uh coach t and riley would get
along
oh yeah i think they got a very similar
mentality yeah
but at all maybe coach t would be a
little bit less impressed with his lack
of desire for leg day i think coach t
would probably
see some more legs out of the boys but
he's a real go-getter yeah
yeah yeah no he he he wants the best set
of his boys for sure he wants the best
out of his team and boys and girls i
should say it's a
you know everyone have you seen that
have you seen a petition online
uh that says they want jared kieso to
play uh wolverine
in the mcu yeah yeah that time yeah
i'm all for that yeah yeah
i mean he's perfect he's a good old boy
with uh
with that farmhand strength you know but
uh i think you could shred it
yeah i'm actually done can you tell us
anything about uh
about the new season of letter candy
quickly before we go
uh it's it's gonna be hilarious and it's
gonna be very
i mean we're all playing like we're a
lot like the fans you know we wanted to
get out there like we look forward to
going out every summer to film letter
kenny as a
as a cast but also as a group of friends
um
i haven't seen the scripts yet they're
under lock and key it's been very
tight-lipped
but i am as thrilled if not more so than
the fans to see what's coming up because
we are ready to start filming we are
stoked to get back to sudbury
right on man
you